i got to tell you like every single time
i see uh the word ricotta
at a gelato it's ricotta it's ricotta
like
[Music]
ricotta
[Music]
hey guys it's mike chan welcome back to
kong heads the coolest sweetest show
on the internet and i gotta be honest
with you guys as much as i
love eating ice cream here from the
comforts of my own home i'm going a
little stir crazy so as things are
starting to open up today
i want to go out for a little socially
distanced
ice cream adventure i've been having ice
cream and pines delivered here all
summer long so
i really want to go out and talk to
these makers these ice cream creators
the people responsible
for keeping my freezer stocked all
summer long and later on
this is really exciting i've arranged a
little international ice cream adventure
with one of my
favorite food personalities so you guys
ready
let's go
what's up guys today i am in front of
snokomi ice cream
this is the place where barry and
charnes bettinger has been cranking out
some of the best
pints in washington state since 1997.
really excited today because i get to go
check out the factory see how the ice
cream is made
and maybe we'll grab a scoop or two for
three let's go
[Music]
how much ice cream do you produce a day
well we do it in
mix i'm not a mix because the amount of
ice cream you get depends on the overrun
yeah how much air you put in it
so typically on a day we do 1500 gallons
of mix
1500 gallons yeah okay
that's a lot of ice cream then we sell
we sell a lot of mix and then we also
make a lot of pints
and we sell quite a bit of tubs how many
flavors do you have
oh in grocery store almost 30 but all
together
easily two or three hundred we're one of
the few companies that do
like everything we buy milk and cream we
make the mix
we we do the pints we can do tubs we do
the single serves
our process is very different than how
most ice cream is made and i can show
you that
yeah let's go let's go check it out
so so this is the popsicle machine yeah
yeah so the way it works is
they're all wrapped individually and
then it goes into our retail pack
wow the magical of an ice cream bar
right here
that's incredible looking machine so
2500 ice cream bars
in an hour
[Music]
so the way we make ice cream we do it in
300 gallon batches
and it's pasteurized at a lower
temperature for
at a longer longer time so most ice
cream mix is pasteurized at about 188
degrees for 22 seconds
we pasteurize it about 160 165 for 30
minutes
by doing it in small batches we can if
like say there's any spices
added the spices gets get cooked in with
the mix
so it's more flavorful very and we can
cut the sugar by a little bit too
because we're caramelizing the lactose
really
yeah so your ice cream in general is
healthier and tastier
well if it's healthier maybe by this one
hey a little bit helps yeah that's a
huge operation
i mean it's not a lot of space oh yeah
but you're cranking out a lot of stuff
oh yeah
i'm at the scoop shop right now and
since uh berry said there's only 12
flavors
so i'll just take that what else do you
recommend uh do you like group your
floats
berry just asked me if i like root beer
floats i gotta tell you
it's one of my uh most favorite things
in the world oh yeah
asking me if i love rubber flows asking
me if i love life socianez is giving me
a bunch of
flavors of ice cream it's hot today too
so this is perfect
all right so the floor flavors i'm
trying vanilla s'mores
chocolate and lavender and seriously the
hottest day of the year
in washington vanilla
[Music]
you can 100 taste the freshness of the
milk there's just something
almost like silken and velvety
the s'mores i love it's like i'm at a
campsite right now
lavender
[Music]
that's my favorite you taste it
but then after about five seconds your
sense is being bombarded with this great
aroma
it's literally like you're eating an ice
cream
and you're walking through a lavender
field
[Music]
incredible what a fun day getting to
meet such a lovely couple
getting to tour an ice cream factory for
the first time in my life chowing down
some delicious ice cream being
transported to
campfires and lavender fields
some days you just love your job and
definitely one of those days for me
[Music]
it felt so good to get out of the
apartment and try some local ice cream
shots but
i'll be honest with you guys i miss
traveling i'm sure everybody out there
does
as well right now i'm actually supposed
to have been in italy
ever since i left last time i just can't
stop thinking about the pizzas
florentine steaks the best sandwich in
the world the gelato
and when you're in italy you always got
to get a gelato okay never a little
always a gelato so i figure i try to go
for a little
italian getaway right here from the
comforts of my own home and
i can't think of anyone better suited to
join me on this incredible journey
than food network legend italian
american icon
jada dilaurentis hey thank you so much
for joining me
hey thanks for having me this is so much
fun can i just say this is like a
bucket list item crossed off by my list
of life
right now obviously you know a lot about
italian food you know a lot about gelato
so
i got to ask you for those who don't
know the difference between
ice cream and gelato what is the biggest
difference the great thing about gelato
is it's creamier
it's silkier it's smoother than ice
cream
now they're both made with cream milk
sugar
but gelato uses mostly milk and very
very little cream sometimes
no cream at all they also whip a lot
more air into ice cream than they do
gelato so again janata tends to be
denser
you don't eat quite as much of it
because every bite just has so much
flavor
and then the last difference i'd say
that really makes a difference in the
flavor profile in the end
is the temperature difference so you
serve gelato about
10 degrees warmer so the flavor profile
of whatever the flavor of gelato is
really hits you because it's warmer i'm
really excited because
we're about to taste gelato from shops
that
you really like in the u.s i got to ask
you though do you feel like
we can do gelato justice here are there
really authentic good
places for gelato in the u.s it'll taste
a tiny bit different
but i think they can do a really good
job here in the us
of giving us as authentic as possible
and i think it comes really close i know
you said uh we're only supposed to eat a
little bit
but we have a lot so you ready to start
eating
let's do it
first off we have this this is one of
your favorite places
[Music]
you're doing this but it's actually joel
[ __ ] said it's very soft
dolce okay
i feel like homer simpson dope peanut
butter straw
chia tella it sounds very romantic
okay i have straight stretch it so
you're going to do the peanut butter one
and i'm going to do the straight
stachatella
just means vanilla and chocolate sachi
are rags
right so it's like something that's
made dirty like it's all white vanilla
and then it has speckles of chocolate
but that's kind of the wording of it
it's speckled with stuff
[Music]
what do you taste that's like a cool
sweet milky silky blinking over my
tongue
i like that that's nice i like that a
lot it's smooth and it's dense
it's not too sweet and you can really
taste the chocolate
and the milk together it's not so sugary
you know what i mean and i do feel like
it's so much
more luxurious i feel like after a
couple bites i'm turning into like a
gelato snob now i'm like oh don't give
me any more ice cream like
gelato yeah well that's what that's what
i'm hoping is gonna happen by the time
we're done
you're never gonna touch ice cream again
you're only gonna ask for jit acting
i'm not going to be able to stop myself
and keep eating so are you ready for the
next one
yes let's do it before i finish this
[Music]
so the second gelato giada you got yours
from where
i got mine from the gelato festival
okay how's it going there's a gelato
festival
it's a store and they make a lot of
great gelati
for a moment i had the biggest fear of
missing out because i'm like there's a
gelato festival where i want to be a
part of that
what do you have i think we both have
chocolate hazelnut now i got mine from
uh
boltega italiana here in seattle
i mean it ain't no gelato festival but
we'll see how it is so this is very
italian and traditional that they put
the chocolate hazelnut
on top underneath it's just vanilla and
i know the blending of chocolate and
hazelnut is like a really
popular flavor in italy um there's a
name for it
it's called uh gianduya
genduya bravo yes that's exactly what it
is
oh my god such a good choice there's no
way i said that correctly
you did great john do ya
how's yours because mine is insane this
is addicting i love the aftertaste of it
it gives it gives off like a
like a fragrant flavor you know like
that great nutty
floral flavor you're right nutty
and just so thick
i mean there's nothing better this
really kind of brings me back to italy
walking around eating gelato letting
that flavor sit on my tongue just kind
of soaking all that
crazy fairy tale atmosphere up and i
could almost do that
if i take a bite of this and close my
eyes a little bit
[Applause]
and that's what great gelato will do you
close your eyes and it transports you
into a memory that you have
of a place that you love i think that's
the gift that food has
and especially gelato i don't want to
get taken
away too far because uh i don't want to
come back
uh you ready for the next one yeah
let's do it so mike this is one of my
favorites
it's ricotta and fig from fata morgana
gelato
fatta morgana is um actually a place
that i've been to
in tuscany and we actually made
this exact gelato from scratch i gotta
tell you like every single time i see
uh the word ricotta at a
i am so excited for these you ready yes
let's do it
oh the spoon is going in so smoothly
i got a chunk of fig did you find some
fig in there oh
i got figged oh yeah it even has the
texture of ricotta
oh no every single bite i take i want to
like inadvertently close my eyes you
know like
like what you do when you're kissing
someone you love
that is the best analogy i love that i
mean this is a flavor that is very
italian it's not really one that a lot
of americans order
you know because it's figs and ricotta
it's for someone who's willing to take a
bit of a journey and gelato but i think
it's fantastic
well this has been incredible thank you
thank you thank you so much yada for
joining me today
seriously one of the best experiences of
my life eating gelato with you
thanks for having me mike it was so much
fun thank you for all the laughs
enjoy gelato all right guys thank you
all so much for watching come heads
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you